welcome everybody we are back the h3
podcast we were not here last week
because we are making an h3 video about
all the protests going on so we are back
and I am very happy to be back today's
episode is sponsored by me undies
stamps.com
add teddy fresh calm got a couple of
reefs stocks in including this shirt and
several others
William Osmond was meant to be a last
week he's going to be next week and
Oliver tree is going to be on July 17th
so with that being said ela you are co
vid free I know that because I went to
with you to get tested we are all Nova
219 free yeah we all got tested and it
was really easy to do which I was so
surprised and we got the results the
next day was it the next day yeah Wow la
is doing a really good job it's crazy so
Dodger Stadium which is in like the
heart of Los Angeles has this massive
parking lot and because of the sports
are shut down currently they turned it
into this massive massive testing mm-hm
site where you drive through with your
car and I was afraid I was gonna get the
straw the the scooper the brain scoop
there's a swab they swab out a piece of
your brain mm-hmm
but actually they they leveled up and
all they do is give you a little swab
you like walk off and slam in your mouth
and you just swab parts of your mouth
and that's it yeah it's awesome I uh
recommend everyone to go get it done if
they can I think it's awesome though
it's available finally I think in LA I
don't know if it's true of the rest of
the world or the rest of the country in
LA for sure
you can get that test done and everybody
I know got it done so it was awesome so
I am I got nervous though when I saw
that email they're like Ethan your kovat
test is end yeah it's like that STD test
when you're in college like oh baby here
we go yeah I mean you know everybody
gets STD tests right you ever got one I
don't even know you might have I'm sure
okay
[Laughter]
Wow you uh we gotta get you tested no I
think I would have noticed by now
probably so let's talk about the
protests I have a lot to say about this
yeah and I'm glad I gave it some time to
breathe I made a video on h3 our main
channel a straight reproductions talking
about my experience with the police
which some of you probably saw and my my
anecdote was simply that I have been
stopped by the police to what Ivan had
to counters with the police in my life
and both times ended without any
incident at all and just totally letting
me off one of the times I had weed and a
bong in my truck and I drove off the
freeway because I was nervous and I
didn't want to pull over on the side of
the freeway because I didn't know what
to do I was a early driver and it was so
shady you know and I'm and I'm thinking
back on those times and I'm like man if
I was black those probably would have
turned out differently and not only that
if I would have gone to jail my whole
life would have been [ __ ] up or if you
just Dan or if I was killed yeah which
is obviously even worse which happened
which is what happened to George Floyd
yeah and this whole black lives matter
movement I'm glad to see that it's
actually gaining ground now because
previously it was oh it was even a
controversial statement to say black
lives matter it was like goes like write
a call yeah was radical for some reason
right but I I think though the
experience that someone like me and most
and us here in this office have like
coming from like white suburbs it's hard
to even honestly fully empathize with
with what the experience of being black
in America you know but I think it's
starting to come into view for people
just like it's the whole system right
from policing police brutality and the
criminal justice system where
States states have contracts from
private prisons and the states have to
guarantee to keep the prisons full it's
mental I don't know if you guys have
seen the Netflix documentary 13th about
the Thirteenth Amendment when slavery
was abolished the 13th amendment they
added one exception for prisoners all
men are free except prisoners can be
slaves and ever since that amendment was
passed
they've been people black people have
been incarcerated mm-hmm right and
painted as criminals and it's really
extraordinary documentary this is a show
it upsetting to watch yeah they make it
very clear how people have used this
they've used all this different
terminology to basically still say
underlying messages of racism like we're
gonna fight this criminals and then they
stay criminal is black people for
nothing they they're not criminals you
know they'll portray them as criminals
and put them in prison and then would
seem scary and and then also the whole
war on drugs the underlying tone was
black people yeah going after black
people right and Mexican as I guess to
yeah
minorities you know yeah but it showed
like after the Civil War ended in the
13th amendment was passed it was really
interesting because they showed how
there was immediately propaganda to
paint African Americans as violent
criminals has like rapists that will go
after white women which is ironic they
point out because it was actually the
the white slave owners who were raping
and victimizing black man since you know
for 250 years and afterwards I think
about this you know you have to
understand that it hasn't been that long
you know like this country people there
was about 250 years of slave
Trading bringing Africans on a boat over
two of the Americas to be slaves and
then after the Civil War there was like
another hundred years of of actual legal
discrimination Jim Jim Crow laws which
is like you can't drink from the same
fountain you get used the same hotels
you can't use the same bathrooms this
kind of [ __ ]
my dad was born in 1950 those laws were
still in the books in 1950 that's crazy
yeah it wasn't that long ago so when you
think about systemic racism and you go
like well sure there's nothing on the
penal code that is racist but think
about this 250 years of slavery a
hundred years of Jim Crow laws which is
actual legal discrimination and then
that's the stuff ended in like 1960 the
1960s was when the civil rights movement
was so that was like 60 years ago now so
you have 350 years of oppression and 60
years and you and people expect black
people who have accumulated the same
amount of wealth and then another part
so this is this is another part of
systemic racism that I think kind of
shows the problem here a large part of
public schools are funded in large part
by property taxes so you live in a
middle class upper middle class or rich
suburb the class the school is gonna be
much better funded because the property
value is much higher if you go to a poor
neighborhood they're getting way less
funding simply by the way that property
tax works it so to that end you have
more poverty you have worst schools that
alone is proven to increase crime lower
education so you have in a way this
systemic racism because you have this
people that were brought here were
enslaved and discriminated against for
hundreds of years and now people
expect them to just they're at an
incredible disadvantage there's just no
way about it and then the system of
oppression about like you know the
privatizing our jails and then states
guarantee to keep these jails full and
so they make laws like
three-strikes-you're-out and the war on
drugs and what was the one and so
they're keeping the prisons full and
they're there they're painting black
people as criminals and thugs and drug
users and they're filling the prisons up
with black prisoners the stats on black
prisoners is is a astounding it's
astounding 25 percent of all prisoners
in the world are in America
yeah at this time is insane and then
what what's the percentage of prisoners
are black it's damn it can you look that
up I think it's like 40 percent even
though yeah I think it's 40 even though
it's looking so black Americans make up
12% of the population and forty percent
of the prison population and by the way
they statistically use drugs as much as
white people but they get arrested for
it like six times more often so that
just looked it up it's a thirty seven
thirty seven percent that's way off I
mean they commit crime at the same rate
as by white people but the whole justice
system is just so corrupt I've been
saying that for a long time I mean we
need to empty these [ __ ] jails this is
a travesty this is a absolute human
travesty that we have so many millions
of people in our prison system right now
for nonviolent offenses and then not to
mention what conditions they're in when
they're in prison and not to mention
what happens when they get out I always
think about that moment when they get
out they have nothing to have to
readjust to whatever happened with
society like everything's different
they have no career
and it starts from zero and it's
actually worse than that because when
you're a felon or even if you have a
criminal history it's stacked against
you because it's harder to get a job you
have to disclose that you have a
criminal record
and you can vote and felons can't even
vote and the thing is like you people
think of prison has like rehabilitation
centers it's not the way I mean that's
true in other countries I think you know
technically speaking you think of prison
it should be for rehabilitating but
actually our prison system is so brutal
so overpopulated so so inhuman it's not
a rehabilitation center it's just a
slavery right and actually they used
this human resource that they have there
to work they do slave labor and a lot of
companies depend on this slave labor
they get paid like eight cents an hour
or something you know what I mean and
then they charge them like two dollars a
minute for phone calls so anyway to go
back to the whole reason reason that
we're here having these protests is that
black people keep getting killed by by
police the stat is that black people on
black people get killed by the police
2.5 times more than white people mm-hmm
the truth is the stats are fuzzy because
police this is shocked police aren't
even required to report it
there's only there's only been an
aggregate by a third party journalists
who started putting this together
because they were trying to figure out
okay well are black people being killed
more than white people about police and
there's no national database nobody
requires the police to report it to a
national database when they kill people
I then they're aggregating gun deaths
right well when you shoot people
George Floyd wasn't killed by a gun
neither was Eric Gardner
they're both choked out
I think those are the two biggest
problems facing our country right now as
priests police brutality and our whole
criminal justice system is just so any
human it's inhuman I don't know I feel
like this this is a real wakening
awakening moment for everyone I agree I
feel myself that I was not aware of so
much yeah that is going on and deep
problems and where they come from that
it really it's crazy I just it's so
heavy and um sad and I feel like people
will make a change now I think I hope so
because you know the truth is that it's
been often said that nobody's free till
everybody's free mm-hmm and you know of
course they say the original sin of
America is that that slavery that our
founding fathers would write that all
men are created equal Wow Wow
having slaves is like the ultimate irony
and then it brings me to this other
point of like the Confederate flag like
people in the south and people people
are flying the Confederate flag and
trying to write it off like it's just
history dude the Confederates were a
bunch of [ __ ] traitors they were
anti-american I love how these people
are proud Americans flying the
Confederate flag there's nothing more
unamerican than the Confederate flag
these are a bunch of [ __ ] traitors
that wanted to ruin America they waged
war on America I'm still learning about
that and I don't understand how is it
even something that is allowed like that
companies have to ban it why is it even
an issue
isn't it obvious that it should be
banned from everything there's been like
a incredible effort to rewrite history
it's funny when the war during the Civil
War
the north and the south [ __ ] hated
each other like hey you think our
country's divided now I mean well
clearly they were dying by the by the
hundreds of thousands but if you try to
fly Confederate
in America after the Civil War you were
to [ __ ] they would have burned that
[ __ ] down because they knew that that
was the flag of traitors and white
supremacy right and so during the 1950's
during like the height of the KKK and
white supremacy and Jim Crow they
started rewriting the history of the
Confederacy like it was about states
rights and it was about our great
heritage and they that's when they
started putting up all these Confederate
statutes because America would never
tolerate Confederate statues back when
the wounds of that war was was fresh
they waited for all the veterans of the
Civil War to die and for people to
forget what that war actually was about
to the point where you could actually
create this propaganda of course many
people know the truth but you convince
enough people that it's about states
rights and our beautiful heritage then
they start putting up statues to
Confederate heroes in the south where a
bunch of black Americans live and of
course what do you think of black
American things when we fly Confederate
flag that's not that's the flag of white
supremacy that's not a flag for you it's
your heritage
you're an American if you're if you are
identifying with the Confederacy then
you're identifying with [ __ ] traitors
that wanted the waged war on America
that's just that's just I mean you could
you could feign ignorance but I don't
know you can't fly a Nazi flag and just
feign ignorance I mean the Confederacy
was a country founded on white supremacy
and slavery they're awful people you
know just straight up how is he not
nationally banned well America you could
fly in a Nazi flag too you know it's a
freedom - a freedom of expression so we
believe in here but I love when people
say Abraham Lincoln was a Republican the
same people who go Abraham Lincoln was a
Republican how can Republicans be racist
are the same people that are flying
Confederate flags you understand that
Abraham Lincoln fought
and died fighting the Confederacy to
free slaves you can't have it both ways
it's crazy it's just so stupid
so on the Confederate statue thing those
things absolutely should be taken down
those guys are traitors bro and white
supremacist always tought if there is
some historic if it's worth to you
something historic put it in a museum
sure you know don't put in this and it's
not a it yeah yeah I mean look if you
want like sure there's a lot of great
Americans from the south but if if
they're known for being Confederate
General or someone who championed the
Confederacy that's that's not a good
reason to honor them those are traitors
and losers and white supremacist that's
just the fact anyway I keep seeing [ __ ]
coming you know I have to admit to like
you you it's occurred to me recently
where it's like you think back during
slavery and you like to think I would
have been on the side of ablution
abolition and you think back during the
Civil Rights and you're like I would
have definitely marched with Martin
Luther King everybody even the
Republicans I saw Glenn back on
oh I respect Martin Luther King more
than any of these liberals and then the
ironic part is like if you realize it we
are in right now a second civil rights
movement for this very same people with
our prison system and with our policing
system so so you we are in that time and
this is that time it's that bad mm-hmm
you know african-americans were putting
in their art and their literature and
they were saying over and over in every
single way that could possibly say it
and people people didn't listen they
didn't really understand
so there's some there's some points here
like whenever I see people saying all
live matter all lives matter this is a
horrible thing to say and I'll tell you
why well I painted an analogy in our
video on h3h3 productions that's like
saying if you if you call if your house
is if there's a house on fire and
there's 20 houses you call the fire
department the fire department comes and
they start start squirting water in all
20 houses and you go why are you
squirting water on all the houses this
house is on fire and then the
firefighter goes well all houses matter
it's like yeah all houses matter but
this one's on fire you know when you say
all lives matter you're basically saying
yeah you know we all got problems right
you're basically saying hey your
problems ain't your problems ain't
nothing more than anyone's that's not
true far from true yeah but also you
could have problems and they can have
problems your what you're doing is
completely dismissing anything they're
trying to say right it's fine you have
problems but they have bigger problems
they have different you wait you got
problems they got problems let's talk
about both problems what's your problem
well if they had if they can have their
basic rights as human beings they have
bigger problems
you know what I mean this is it needs to
be addressed your regular problems they
have that - yeah you know but they have
more problems on top of that I totally
agree with you I'm just I'm trying to
frame it in a way where it's like if you
think as a white person you have issues
we can talk about those but we can also
talk about the black Oh like why do you
refuse to set yourself aside for a
minute right and understand that you're
not the center of everything and that
someone else is actually having it worse
than you I think I think these people
are like well I got a shitty job and I'm
broke and everyone i knows
bro and they are - yeah and on top of
that they have to be afraid of walking
in the street and getting shot by a
police guy for no reason mm-hmm and
dying you know it's like yeah we all got
problems but you're you can drive you
can call the freeway and yeah you can
call the police
black people feel like a lot of black
people feel like they can't call the
police I bet you they have to think
about it twice you know before they do
what is it worth it
there's so many of you I was watching
this video shot block shop owner calls
the police to report a robbery and then
they show up and beat the [ __ ] out of
the shop owner and arrest him that's why
black people don't call the police
yeah it was even worse than that right
they walk past the dude oh that actually
was yeah and he was like on his way out
and they like rush past him so all lives
matter is honestly I would say at best
it's a extremely ignorant rude and
dismissive and that worse is just
straight-up racist mm-hmm so that's what
people that's what it really means all
lives matter
it's just ignorant don't come at me and
tell me say all lives matter that has
nothing to do with what they're saying
anyway yeah okay all lives matter that's
that has nothing to do with that they're
saying they're not saying all lives
don't matter they're saying we as buyers
laughs problems that we need to talk
about they're saying they would like to
get to the point that we're all lives
matter but we're not there it's just
like it's just it's such a it's just so
really it's just a awful argument and
then you have people like Candace Owen
for example who are taking the angle of
trying to assassinate the character of
George Floyd and this happens very much
is the worst this really is in my
opinion the absolute pits absolute yes
of just toxicity you're talking about a
person who died and has a a mourning
family right now yeah you want to go on
about his
character now what does it matter it
doesn't so Candice Owen is a right she's
she's a black female she's very
articulate but she's like a very
conservative I don't even know how to
describe her but she made a video on
Facebook
Harel show a little bit of it that went
like mega viral on Facebook and all over
the place she's known for for making
these kinds of statements so it doesn't
come as a surprise to anyone obviously
but this to me is the absolute most
terrible inhuman argument to make I'll
just play the beginning part for you
hello Facebook family I have decided to
do this video it has been weighing very
heavily on my heart and on my mind as
well and it was something that I wanted
to say early on but there were so many
emotions and so much pressure for me to
go with the popular opinion about who
George Floyd was and sometimes it can be
difficult when there were just so many
external pressures to say what you
believe and this was an instance where I
felt like my silence would have been
better in the beginning but the more
that I think about it I realized that we
are being sold a lot of Lies and at the
detriment to the black community at the
detriment to the white community and at
the detriment to America as a whole so I
want to come out and say that I do not
support George Floyd and the media
depiction of him as a martyr for black
America I'm going to explain why and I
hope that some of you guys will
understand where I'm coming from I have
spent a considerable amount of so she
goes on from here for 18 minutes to talk
about everything she just a totally
assassinators character that he went to
prison for armed robbery 18 or 13 years
ago what that he shouldn't be the hero
of yeah he's not a martyr she says but
here's the thing
she says she goes on and on about all
these terrible things he's done but
here's the thing nobody is saying he's a
great his character is not in question
you're not mad his care it could have
been you know it
could have been uh it could have been
anyone it doesn't matter who it was the
fact of the matter is that a cop kneeled
on his neck for nine minutes straight
until he literally died right there on
the street in front of people he wasn't
resisting he wasn't doing anything to
warrant that he did barely even
committed a crime and it doesn't
nobody's making him a martyr that's best
again that's like a straw man argument
same as same as the whole lives matter
nobody's making that argument so instead
of actually dressing the issue of police
brutality she's destroying his character
assassinating his character to change
the argument into oh don't make him a
martyr he was a bad guy the police
didn't know anything about him when they
killed him actually that's not true the
guy the cop who murdered him worked with
him the guy who kneeled on his neck for
nine minutes worked with him at a
nightclub and they apparent reportedly
they had beef because the cop was using
excessive force on people and George
Floyd did not like him and was often
telling him to ease up on people so this
cop knew George Floyd has history with
him and then he comes kills him when
he's on duty so he might change to first
degree
first-degree murder if you ask me and by
the way this cop that killed George
Floyd has a long history of violent
abuse and reports and yada yada yada
yada yada and guess what this guy's just
he's just out there terrorizing the
community and he stays on the force it
reminds me a lot of how the church just
shuffled around pedophiles this is same
[ __ ]
bad-apple they go which is a couple of
bad apples so we'll just shuffle them
around okay bad apples don't usually
kill people you know so anyway she goes
on and actually Dave Chappelle put out
this 30-minute speech with a couple of
punchlines yeah that's a good way to put
it
it's on YouTube actually on the Netflix
YouTube channel
and he says he responds to Candace Owen
by saying we didn't choose him the cops
chose him and killed him so he's the guy
mm-hmm it's got nothing to do with this
character as just another deflection you
know and then the other argument so
people are saying let's defund the
police I gotta say I'm for Minneapolis
where this crime originally happened the
the City Council voted to defund the
police now what does it mean to defund
the police what that means is to move
the budget around the police budget is
enormous for example here in Los Angeles
the proposed budget out of a 10 billion
general fund 3.1 billion is going to the
LAPD
Los Angeles one-year yeah that's the
year it was proposed for next year of
course now because of all of the not
anymore right exactly so so people are
asking and rightfully so why are we do
we keep investing and heavily and
policing
we are militarizing the police we are
arming our place to the teeth why are we
putting money here and not putting money
in communities and schools and social
services and housing for the poor if you
invest there then you don't need the
police they're saying they're saying
there's a better different way to do
this and you and I have to agree with
them yeah I have to agree also once you
start to look into the origin of how the
police started and how things have
happened historically like watching the
13 documentary they showed that the
Democrats kept losing to Republicans
because they weren't pushing the agenda
of like hard on crime hard on crime we
got a basically you say hard on crime
underlying tone of it is that you're
gonna go after black people that's what
it was
and the Republicans kept pushing for
that and they want and then when Bill
Clinton wanted to win he had to do this
whole policy of going really hard on
police funding I'm not that well
informed on what exactly it did but he
yeah bill clinton actually he kind of
made it way worse yeah bill clinton and
you know who the architect of that bill
was yeah Alec or or Hillary was it
Hillary go ahead down you Joe Biden Oh
Joe Biden Joe Budden recurrent solomon
ii i will say that to bills credit he
has come out since then and said that
that was the greatest mistake of his
presidency and it's hard to you know
these guys are just playing this game
right they're playing this political
game and like they don't like imagine
like they're playing the oh i want to be
President and then they're and then they
don't think about or maybe they do maybe
there's just that cynical and evil but
they're I think they're just playing
their house of cards right but Bill
Clinton invented this term of super
predator and that these people are just
evil and they need to go to jail and I
believe it was it Bill Clinton that
invented the three strikes you're out
well you didn't invent it but but you're
right that the three strikes is for any
crime no matter how small on the third
one you get locked up for a long time or
life I don't remember but extremely
punitive anyway that I think the reason
I brought it up is because they show in
that documentary how how much the police
was really a way of going after black
people after slavery was ended because
they still couldn't just be okay with
black people being free and so they
wanted to go after them for crime and
for being criminals right and they
weren't but so the police is
consistently being heavily funded in
those ways to go for those reasons after
black people for being I don't know it's
just it's just been like racist in the
beginning
and now this is the result so it was
like they were saying that the police
establishment is deeply wiped
supremacist from the onset like in the
south their economy was heavily reliant
on slavery and so when slavery was
abolished they took a major hit
economically and then as a way to to
kind of trying to bring back the black
people into the fold of slave labor they
were arresting them for like minor
crimes and they're making laws to target
them and so that they could just keep
them a perpetual state of being
prisoners so they could use them as
slave labor but the question of D from
the police is why do we continue to
increase it goes back to that great
adage right it's like an ounce of an
ounce of prevention is better than a
pound of go ahead and correct me quickly
I don't know I don't know we're on so
prevention is better than a pound of
fixing it I feel like George Bush right
now get fooled up fool me twice I can't
filming again don't get fooled again but
past the 30-minute mark just to give you
a heads up it's an ounce of prevention
is worth a pound of cure there you go
who said that Zachary very wise I just
googled who said that I bet you as a
slave owner Benjamin Franklin I'm not
saying just think it was a founding
father tributed oh it's unattributed
okay but that's that that that in
principle is what this is right it's
like we keep we keep attacking the
symptom which is like let's say crime
and poverty and what really you just
want to get people in jail so we're
investing in the police please but we're
not addressing the actual cause which is
that we have poor people poor
neighborhoods bad schooling bad social
services no support for the mentally ill
shitty schools shitty housing options
for the homeless it's like instead of
supporting and it's just not humane
we have to support our community but
instead we're investing in the police
that are punishing them so instead of
uplifting them the same money that could
up with them is going to money to punish
and police them it's crazy I'm not
saying get rid of the police entirely
you keep a force that's dedicated to
violent crimes shootings Violent Crimes
etc etc that's where the police should
be what they should be doing but if you
get a call about someone who's doing
drugs or making lots of noise or a
non-violent offense or yadda-yadda-yadda
you don't need armed police storm
troopers showing up ready with their
finger on the trigger that's how George
Floyd and Eric garner were killed dudes
who are doing nothing and so that that
in principle is is what defund the
police means and I actually fully
support it I think it's so important
that we change the system John Oliver
episode also pointed out how there's
just too much that is being put under
the police umbrella like they're they
just have to take care of everything
everything everyone yeah they're not
even equipped for it I don't even know
how yeah he showed up he showed a speech
from a police chief I forget what city
and who said it but he's like look
frankly you guys the police are doing
way too much mm-hmm they're just doing
way too much we you you instead of
having the police do it have people who
are better trained for that their
specific task you can't expect a police
offer who's trained to deal with
violence they're violent they deal with
violence and they take on risks and
they're trained for that so it's only
it's almost hard for example to even
like it's better for them to just put
them in this places where they're
trained to be because when they're all
on edge and they're trained to use their
weapon and they're thinking like that
when they show up to something that
doesn't really require that level of
force of course they're gonna go there
more often
I mean it's just like any other field in
the world or any in a business you you
have specialized people doing
specialized things definitely you just
need to separate and have people
specialize in specific things yes their
duty I mean the cops just wear too many
hats they're required to do too many
things and they're really not good at
all those things and and and the police
training by nature is um they're not
trained to do those things they're
trained to be police this is by the way
the budget for LA of the discretionary
ten billion that the mayor has this is
how much he's putting into LAPD versus
housing a community transportation recs
and parks Cultural Affairs emergency
management that just to give you an idea
I mean that's [ __ ] outrageous you
know and then imagine a black person you
work you pay taxes and all and like this
huge vast majority of the taxes you're
paying is going to a people that you
don't even feel comfortable calling
you're that you're afraid of you know so
that's that's what defund the police
means let's throw it to a quick break
and we will come back and continue this
conversation don't go away
thank you to me on DS for sponsoring us
makers of the most luscious beautiful
soft underwear and the game made of
micro modal which is just about a
billion times softer than cotton I think
they have measured that scientifically
and nice beautiful soft underwear makes
a great gift for Father's Day
ela mm-hmm I want to be celebrating
Father's Day this year right hmm
Samiha undies sounds good my first pair
of me undies I put on honestly was like
a cloud around my genitals and I got to
tell you I usually just wear this normal
cotton it's rough sometimes it rubs on
the on the tip of your penis and
sometimes it just doesn't feel that good
to be honest but the me on DS is soft
its breathable you know it's just
everything right it doesn't write up it
doesn't give you a wedgie it's just
everything right about underwear so me
undies Mandy's has the brilliant thing
called undies membership where every
month the softest undies ever appear at
your door the convenience factor is
clutch and you never have to leave your
house oh and get this you get site-wide
savings early access and free shipping
is pure joy because when undies greet
you in your mailbox June gloom June
gloom is doomed me undies is made from
micro modal and an irresistible soft
sustainable fabric that in cases your
nether regions and cloud like comfort
its magically made from trees and other
reasons to give them a hug
they have sizes ranging from extra small
to 4 XL dude I'm like push it I'm like
to excel these days bro I'm trying hard
though but good the good news is I have
two more sizes to throw into me undies
has a great offer for our listeners if
you're a first-time purchase served me
on DS you get 15% off and free shipping
so you got to give this a try if you're
just out there wearing ordinary
underwear you don't know what you're
missing out with me undies supersoft and
they about 100% satisfaction guaranteed
so if you don't like it boom you get
your money back no risk no reason not to
try
so get 50% off your first order free
shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed by going to me Indies comm /
h3 that's me on DS dot-com / h3
for all of our sake we need to be
avoiding crowds right now any way we can
but what if you need to go to the post
office what if you need to send a
package out letters packages whatever
well don't worry because stamps.com is
here to help with stamps calm you can
print postage on demand and skip those
lines and crowds at the post office plus
you actually save money with discounts
that you can't get at the post office
and if that wasn't enough stamps calm
also offers UPS services with discounts
up to 62 percent and no UPS residential
surcharges stamps Elcom brings you all
the services of the US Postal Service
right to your computer and the safety
and comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else you may be hunkering down
right now whether your small business
sending invoices or an online seller
shipping out products or you're just
working from home and need to mail stuff
Sam's comp can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready you just leave it with your mail
carrier schedule a free pickup or drop
it in the mailbox no human contact is
required isn't that simple ain't that
the beauty buddy like I said at Sam's
Calm you get great discounts - five
cents off every first-class stamp and up
to 62 percent off of shipping rates so
stamps calm is a no-brainer
especially now saving you time and money
and keeping you safe in these crazy
times right now for our listeners we've
got a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type h3 that stamps comm and enter
h3 stay safe my friends
so we are back welcome back then when
you get really deep in the hole of weird
counter-arguments you've got queueing on
who try to untangle this one yo oh yeah
this is my [ __ ] right here so we've got
what we've got like six seven eight ten
question marks four circles 20 arrows
now here is their theory and you can
draw your conclusion from this why do we
see lines on the dark pavement but do
not on the light pavement Oh
so here's a line like the answer lies
within the question why do we see lines
in the dark but not on the light because
it's easier to see on the dark but here
but you look you would think that why
don't you see a line here there's a line
it actually looks like the line is like
I kind of did see there right here right
wait no which one are you talking about
so this is apparently the same here's
the line which line these lines this
line yeah well in this picture it's too
close yeah it's too close I think your
line is right here yeah so I don't know
why circling right here is no they're
talking about that line that is next to
his head I think this line is next to
his head yeah the seven that I do see it
versus you can't see his head in this
one where did the line go that's the
point
ela go ahead unpack it for me you see
the line there you go Wow is this a joke
disoriented Joe dan says it's real Oh
unfortunately it is very real is this
the same Street the police car move why
are the lines different why are the
lines different why are the lies that
robbed their friend that's what you
think but how do you know where did the
lines go you look big Eric go hold on
no white line on the black pavement
visible white line where is the white
line now I love that they make all this
hysteria over the white line but I still
don't understand what's the implication
or even the point of this conspiracy you
know what I mean like okay we have it on
video what does it mean what does the
white line
there's something else going on here I'm
how fake do you understand
okay to fake this video you would need
there was like a ton of people gather
around so you need a bunch of actors you
need a closed set you need to close off
the stress of that registry ins walking
by weren't able to capture this fake
event you would need the police to not
the but but how did you so then the
police are on it because he obviously
murdered George Floyd so you need these
police to take the fall and not say it's
fake it's it's like oh I think I I could
be wrong but I think that he in in in
cue and on world he didn't actually die
they faked his death he's still alive
but what he but the guy kneeled on his
neck for nine minutes yeah but he was
you know as a stunt it's like a movie
so everybody is in on it everybody's in
on it wow that is that is an impressive
conspiracy I mean these people have no
problem stretching their imagine
remember that Alex Jones thought that
Sandy Hook was an entire like faked
event with tons of actors that yeah I
mean it's not unprecedented right well
that one practice at this Sandy Hook
would be way harder to coordinate than
this this is small potatoes compared to
that right exactly exactly
imagine faking the death of like dozens
of kids so anyway that's my whole spiel
you know look I I'm trying to avoid
politics in general but I do personally
feel like this is very important this is
a defining issue of our time and I don't
want to I feel like it'd be a little bit
cowardly of me to just not speak up on
something like this because I know it's
going to upset people I feel like in
this case this is different and this is
a time that there's a real movement
right now that I think is really
important to keep keep it going until
there's real change because it just
can't happen
again it's just not there can't be
another George Floyd it cannot happen
again it happens like every week
unfortunately that's unacceptable and I
think that any especially as being not
being black we have a responsibility to
take part in this and do whatever we can
and educate ourselves which is something
I personally been trying to do try to
educate ourselves and try to understand
why are things the way our and where are
the points where change can actually
happen mm-hmm like they're saying with
voting I don't know beyond just the
presidential candidate like all day the
more local election yeah local elections
hmm voting for your da that's a big one
that most people ignored
well the Minneapolis City Council are
the ones who are able to abolish the
police mm-hmm defund the police rather
so I feel like this isn't really a
political issue it's like a human's
right yes it's you I don't know how it
became political I really don't really
it's just some people refused to accept
me not that alcove it became a political
issue here I don't know how yeah that I
think ovid becoming a political issue is
truly mind-bending to me at speaking of
and and again I have to I don't like
talking about Trump here because people
get upset
but I have to bring this one up because
Trump tweeted about the 70 year old guy
we all saw the video of the 75 year old
guy who got pushed over by the police
cracked his head open on the sidewalk
that was bleeding out of his ears we all
saw that video and had like a trillion
gazillion views and we all saw it and
were like wow this is [ __ ] crazy
Donald Trump tweets out everybody hold
on to that G or seat Buffalo protester
shoved by police could be an Tifa
provocateur 75 year old martin Gugino
was pushed away after appearing to scan
police communications in order to black
out the equipment
so this guy the 75 year old man over
this video we all saw was attempting to
black out all their communications by I
don't know he had his phone in his hand
and then they say I watched he felt
harder than pushed was aiming scanner
could be a setup
he felt harder than he pushed this is a
75 year old man that was able to
catapult himself to the concrete and
crack his dome and intentionally give
himself permanent brain damage
right oh this is the tweet that oh that
there was a I was like wow this is peak
insanity like this has got to be too far
for like everybody right not for 200,000
people no I think a lot of people like
Trump's tweets maybe ironically I don't
know what or really that's real
you think so yeah I think so would you
like ironically well they're like dude
look at this crazy ass tweet I might
retweet it for that yeah maybe right
like but I mean like I mean a lot of
that is like peak insanity garbage right
glad you agree team hmm game start what
do you think about the that's that 75
year old really crossed the line he
crossed the line well I don't I disagree
with you sir I think that's just an
awful thing to say you're a [ __ ]
hypocrite hey don't talk about not God
that guy did not deserve any of that out
there you said keep sorry you were way
over the line to speak about him like
that guy's garbage hey come on have some
respect for the man
good luck Ethan cuz you're gonna [ __ ]
all right she's worth thing get heated
about his friend tweeted this out he
goes kind of surreal when the president
starts accusing your 75 year old friend
of being an agent of an tyfa my friends
george Gugino is an old man with cancer
was now in the hospital with brain
damage after being pushed to the ground
by police officer he was trying to talk
to
there you have um George Oh Martin
Martin's Eugene or joy
George came from did I say George that's
what Zach he said George Oh Yugi no
Martin Gigi no that video was kind of
traumatizing I can't watch it I watched
it already so many times because it was
over the news and everything and I can't
but it's like so that was like one of
the most horrible things I've seen and
then Trump yeah why would you say I'd
you notice the consequence though
because you have all these crazy
queueing on people and all these wild
conspiracy actors who are now gonna pick
that up and target this poor guy and his
family it's just crazy
oh and then the NYPD makes a statement
because they're upset about all the [ __ ]
they're getting from protesters and this
this here's a little excerpt from their
their meeting new york police boss mike
O'Meara went off on the media today by
someone in Minneapolis it's still got a
shine on it by the way they killed Eric
garner and so nothing like it so do this
stop treating us like animals and thugs
and start treating us with some respect
isn't that what black people say you
treat them like forever how could you
take it for a week and you're out there
crying like a little [ __ ] how can you
be son not self-aware because the police
state they don't get [ __ ] they don't
take [ __ ] they give [ __ ]
let's end this little [ __ ] baby he
thinks he's in a movie or same thing so
do this
we still got shine on our badge damn it
the talks like that we ain't never
killed nobody here in New York City this
guy's like a caricature I know and start
treating us with some respec how about
you take shift for one week not fall
apart like a little baby mud birds still
got shine on it
okay Scorsese that's what we're here
today to say we've been left out of the
conversation we've been good maybe it's
not your time to talk maybe sure time to
listen right hmm maybe you get to talk
you've been talking for decades maybe
just shut the [ __ ] up and actually
listen to what people are saying I mean
it's kinda just proves the whole point
of the movement it's like falling on
deaf ears hostile ears disgusting it's
disgusting
trying to make us embarrassed about
profession 375 million interactions so
with the George Floyd video yeah you
would you have you know that well no he
says oh that happened in Minneapolis my
badge still got shine on it but
obviously he and I cannot build me oh
yeah of course
positive nobody talks about all the
police officers that were killed in the
last week in the United States of
America and there were a number of them
yeah well police officers haven't have
an expectation that it's a dangerous job
that they signed up for
it's tragic whenever an officer loses
its life but black people don't are not
expecting to be murdered by the police
like that's that's not something that's
expected to happen I mean it's it's a
it's a very bad comparison to say well
police are murdered in the line of duty
which is a dangerous job that we all
signed up for and it's expected to
happen in the course of our duty you
know to some of us tragic as it may be
that's what makes you a hero right you
want to be a hero you want to be a hero
he wants to be treated like a hero but
George Floyd was murdered yes this is
why we're all here talking it's got
nothing to do with cops there's nothing
to lie do with any of that but sometimes
no one is saying that every single one
of these people in this group are evil
you know what I mean I feel like it's
such a a lot of people are saying that
there is a there's a big movement right
now I see it everywhere it's all cops
are bastards
ACAB so there are a lot of people saying
all cops are bastards and I think what
they mean is that look at how weapon and
George would you have one guy killing a
dude and three guys sitting there
protecting him right so it's the whole
it's the fraternity it's the cult eNOS
it's the whole system it's the whole
thing or the police apparatus is a
problem yeah and I mean this kind of
proves their point I got defensive these
I'm also adding a solidary like it the
guy to 75 year old when the cop was
punished then they all so decided to
resign whatever that means there was
really a resign two cops got arrested
for shoving that 75 year old man over
and all of the other cops like 60
something of them resigned in protest in
support of the two cops
yeah did they get arrested
yeah they got charged for assault oh
okay I hadn't heard that yeah they'd the
two officers got charged for assault
well and then the officers one point
that I do know is that they didn't
actually resign from being police
writers they just resigned from the task
force oh yeah they still get they're
still getting paid by the way there's no
what I saw that I was like it'd be nice
to have a job where I can just resign
from [ __ ] that I don't feel like doing
anymore right Ethan I resign from doing
the highlights
actually I like channel I'm just like
damn I gotta hire someone else down yeah
well you still have to pay me for
everything else by the way I noticed how
all the more wearing masks but just this
one guy's like I'm not gonna [ __ ]
wear masks
he had a [ __ ] I'm not normal
maybe he was also speaking or something
I don't know yeah that's probably true
we don't get though Minneapolis we
roundly reject what he did and roll your
Police Department does the same things
what the [ __ ]
disgusting it's disgusting it's not what
we do Salwa police officers do
well on the plate I just lay there's a
big reading off the press is vilifying
us well you know what guys I'll probably
be a cop and I'm gonna continue to be
proud to be okay you know what guys we
rule this is this isn't about you
personally like he's taking it personal
like you said how about just listen yeah
and they're all there in solidarity like
totally missing the point
why you guys being so brutal yeah I know
and then of course people are protesting
police brutality and the police respond
with police brutality yeah beautiful
thank you for proving everything they
the police have been doing has totally
been proving their point over and over
and over again
NASCAR bans the Confederate flag which i
think is a huge move people should not
be flying the Confederate [ __ ] flag
people are not happy by the way the
Komets are gold this is this is
ridiculous you can't erase history
argument is what wait what history are
they erasing yeah put it in a book it is
in a book so what do you want I'm sorry
I hate you more and more I will support
local tracks more than I will support
NASCAR I hate you you have become
political all of a sudden you will lose
more fans just like the NFL did
now just put this in perspective these
are the kind same kind of messages
people were getting schools we're
getting restaurants public places we're
getting when they allowed black people
to come share the same space as white
people it's the same [ __ ] messages
and everybody likes to think back then
and be like oh I wouldn't support that
it's people were sending the same
messages okay it's the same [ __ ]
different [ __ ] day
let's see pretty soon we will all have
radios in the car playing rap music okay
interesting oh here we go all its ever
meant is heritage my Southern roots run
deep I'm proud of that and I always will
be you shouldn't be your son bro these
are guys
these are traitors to America I mean
that's like a German by the way and the
Confederacy was short-lived it's not
like deep Southern roots the Confederacy
they existed for like five years and
they were defeated and abolished the
Confederacy has nothing to do with
Southern roots yeah the flag isn't even
that wasn't even the flag of the
Confederacy is literally the flag of one
of the armies like it's explicitly just
the flag of people that actively fought
America look at this why must we always
have to give in destroy our history's
uncivil and embarrassing I mean it's
literally the same person from a person
in Germany being like hey dude I'm gonna
fly I swear to god this I'm not being
hyperbolic it's a German person flying a
Nazi five million a dog is my history
it's not it's got nothing to do with
Nazism it's just my history bro
my deep my deep Nazi history there is
some of that sentiment and because many
but it's a the Confederacy only existed
for five years it's got nothing to do
with southern identity nothing the
Confederacy was about white supremacy
and slavery it's crazy and it shouldn't
be flown [ __ ] them [ __ ] the Confederacy
[ __ ] the Confederate [ __ ] traitor
asked losers
so that's great I mean NASCAR is pretty
much middle America so you know there's
lots of pushback but changes inevitable
and people will get over it
and then in 20 years all their kids will
be like that was [ __ ] up you know what
I mean like us looking back on Jim Crow
and segregation and we were like that
was so [ __ ] up mm-hmm that'll be 20
years to this website's awesome
this website is called
one angry gamer you could say that again
this is one angry gamer traders of
America I love that he's a gamer and
he's just angry he's got a list of
traitors to America which is very
comprehensive adidas for example let's
see what they did it's a very
comprehensive website so adidas tweeted
up one three together is how we move
forward together is how we make change
so this was their traitorous tweet so I
just think looks like it was just
supporting something Nike tweeted yeah
it was a Nike must be really in the
[ __ ]
you know let's see I'll be part of the
same changed Nike says it's a black
lives matter thing I think so
so they's are traitors to America
Amazon's a double traitor Oh sounds bad
Amazon donates ten million dollars to
organizations supporting justice equity
traders Adult Swim traitors we stand
with our black colleagues black lives
matter so standing your way to black
colleagues is the traitor tumor a
traitor to white America which is what
it means which is what the Confederacy
was all about so these are all companies
that are traitors and if you're not on
this list you should be you should be
wondering why you're not on this list
basically you should be on this list you
should be worried
let's eat celebrities Andrew yang god
bless you glad to see what did he do
traitor I like how it just takes one
Italy so reference I mean this is a
really good he's very thorough website
yeah black lives matter
mayor grief lead us
traitor you [ __ ] traitor
uh let's see here
there's so many just like Andy Miller
what did he do that traitor deal wait
wait
Anita sarkeesian destroyed the entire
gaming industry do you see that I'll
click that Andy said after having a
tweet that blew up worldwide and seeing
the trash and honest racists in the
comments made me a little jaded I'll do
a charity Twitter stream for Minnesota
freedom fund because I think it's the
right thing to do and more effective
than a Twitter post with my feelings you
traitor you traitor to white America
yeah the entire game there are no video
games and wait you guys realize but
there just there is in video games over
I love that people get their own titles
to awesome this website's really cool
right now we are seeing so many folks
generously give however much they can to
help the people and organizations doing
more important work today
I gave to two very different NACA
yada-yada-yada who cares about your
traitor how dare you
Oh ariana grande war a micro skirt to a
funeral
I love how conservative is what did she
wear by the way can you pull up whatever
she wore to a funeral she just she she
tweeted about black lives matter so
obviously she's a traitor
you know this website so fun and I love
how it's just so well sourced Britney
Spears the first one funeral we know but
they have the proof they have the
receipts of everybody every traitor it's
one tweet it's awesome though like it's
so easy to reference Chris Reagan is an
insincere traitor Oh what what
interesting oh I love Twitter
oh one angry gamer has a has a Twitter
account he said we've updated the list
why is that insincere oh because he
doesn't love Twitter okay
critical mmm sorry well I'm glad to see
critical on the list congratulations
former world's best slap fight did you
find the skirt yeah I said it was a
wreath of Franklin's funeral hey that
doesn't look that bad a micro skirt Bill
Clinton has kept his köppen look isn't
he did Bill such a horndog Billy Boy
old Billy Boy but you know black people
generally really like the Clintons isn't
that true they really like Bill Clinton
despite the fact that it was like hard
on crime and it's a complicated history
I mean yeah it was very complicated and
even black people he's a southern didn't
really realized what they were voting
for and then we're voting I don't want
to speak out of turn I don't understand
the complexion of that I know I mean I'm
just all of my research is basically
watching the 13th documentary but it was
very informative game grumps or traders
h3h3 disgraced now is I it's just a
disgrace does that worse is that worse
or better than traitor well I think it's
interesting because it's not
instead of traitor it's instead of your
occupation you see how everybody else
it's like what they do I'm just oh I
just disgraced that's my that's my
occupation title huh interesting
black lives matter this was when I
became a traitor well I'm glad I'm on
this list I think I took too long to get
on it to be honest I think it was a
problem that I only now I'm on this list
so I'm glad to be on it I'm glad to be a
traitor to America Justin Bieber
congratulations
ksi is a traitor beat the snot out of
Logan Paul wait that sounds like a good
thing well again that's his um that's
just his title that's what he's known
for he's a traitor though he's not a
youtuber he's mainly known for beating
up Logan Paul
but you get the idea you can you can
really dig in here it's it's fantastic
it really is so shout out to one angry
gamer which is true to name the Beatles
mmm are you gonna call the Beatles
traitors are not even Americans black
lives matter
The Beatles didn't have anything to do
with this none of them are dead yeah are
you gonna post are you are you gonna
play him like that
how dare you put up for 50 years I mean
Jesus yeah come on dude show some
respect
spread the anger that somebody says when
he's promoting his as social this is not
love it love love love and then of
course finally the celebrities wouldn't
be much and without embarrassing
themselves and making another
collaborative video apologizing for
white privilege now you have to you
after the last time this happened with
imagine you would think that people
would be wiser cuz they all did that
imagine thing by gal gadot and everybody
got clowned on so hard and so they says
you know what we should do let's all
collab and make a video about our white
privilege you know that imagine thing
yeah yep from our perspective everybody
clowned on them but I'm pretty sure in
like norm a Facebook world that was a
hit yeah really I mean like you said I
mean why would they do something like
that again if it was all negative
reaction I thought see that yeah when
you're not on Facebook you kind of man I
know there's two types of people in the
world people on Facebook and people not
disdain age Twitter I'm on Twitter
unfortunately Twitter is just a place
that come feel bad I've been I've been
feeling really bad since all this
happened I had to part you've been on
your phone like and
every minute that I see you basically
you know there's a lot going on you have
to you're on your how could you even
criticize always on your phone well if I
am it's like work I'm talking to me to
do an important [ __ ] what do you think
I'm doing
Twitter Twitter's part of my work
changing the world baby every tweet
every time I retweet police brutality I
changed the world
don't you understand the importance of
my work I also donated $10,000 just so
everybody doesn't clown on me we thank
you you're right I should have said we I
don't know why I said I well I was the
what I was the one taking heat for
making this were you trying to donation
shame either yeah no I was trying to not
give her any credit different that's a
different activation but we donated
thank you yes we did I do do that
sometimes
ela and I should say we instead of I
it's just rude Ethan where are your
manners parents my parents they
obviously didn't teach me any quick
aside are you wearing the necklace from
Titanic yes okay that too is it actually
like a replica of that yeah that's sick
what's it called the heart of the ocean
thanks no and how much was that was it
100 million no 75 was it expensive
my necklace yeah expensive but not like
real stones or any things no no not
expensive like that okay so anyway
here's the celebs are back we regret to
inform you the subs are back at it again
here we go now I every time I hear black
people talking about they're in
Kreuzberg again I look I'm a white dude
so Who am I to to lecture them but they
always say don't apologize for white for
all this [ __ ] just [ __ ] donate
and help you know we don't want your
crocodile tears why is this black and
white which is embarrassing it's just
it's just so corny but here we go
let's watch I
take responsibility I take
responsibility I'm what that's right Oh
am I gonna get claim for this sad-ass
music do we know I don't know what is I
take responsibility org by the way to
them they will website let's just
dispute it if it claiming responsibility
I take responsibility for being oh my
god for every time it was easier than to
call it out for what it was every not so
funny joke every unfair stereotype every
blatant injustice no matter how big or
small every time I remain silent every
time I explained away police brutality
or turned a blind eye I take
responsibility
black people are being slaughtered in
the streets killed in their own homes
these are Lauder distance I thought
people say like it's kind of salah dirt
in the streets
Rollo's and sisters our friends our
family we are done watching them die we
are no longer bystanders we will not be
idle enough is enough I will no longer
allow and unchecked a moment I will no
longer allow racist hurtful words jokes
stereotypes no matter how big or small
the minute implication is that they've
been doing that allowing racist jokes
and stuff they understand take
responsibility dot-org
coming from and I think that at least
they're trying to do something nice okay
I feel that and why I think they're
saying it like that because so they're
speaking for all white phial didn't
really understand what was happening
they speak are all white people
I take responsibilities for white people
that come sign up and pledge to never
let another racist joke slide listen I
will not turn a blind eye
going for a jog should not be a death
sentence sleeping in your own home
should not be a death sentence playing
video games with your nephew should not
be a death sentence shopping in a store
should not be a death sentence business
as usual
should not be life threatening I stand
against hate I stand against hate I
stand against hate I stand against hate
I will stand against you I do I will
make my presence known and killer cops
must be prosecuted they are murderers we
can turn the tide it is time to take
responsibility call out hate step up and
take action so I heard I heard I saw
some black people saying it's like the
white Savior thing or it's like all the
white people come in and then they save
the day but it's like a black people's
movement you should let them take the
lead why is this so cringy can you
unpack this I think it's a black and
white the music and some of them try to
talk like do dramatic acting yeah
they're delivering a line like some of
them talked like themselves and the
people were okay but it's the ones I'm
like people are me the streets Matthew
McConaughey yes Aaron Paul in particular
was auditioning chill but worse imagine
by gal gadot or dis how do they Calvados
is worse why's this one I mean their
intentions is good obviously it's just a
little corny the guy adult one was just
a weird crazy that one was just bizarre
that one was just me wrong feels a bit
that it's a bit odd that they didn't say
racism at any point then why didn't they
just talked about hate talk about hate
exactly that way it's like I guess those
are somewhat interchangeable but
is he in here by the way did he arrive
he is yes actually
Ian how are you my on yes
hello I'm doing as good as I could Ian
slept walked and kicked the wall or some
[ __ ] what happened you uh yeah I have a
sleepwalking problem and normally it's
pretty pretty relaxed I wake up with
pants on that I didn't fall asleep
wearing or I like I'm hugging my
bookshelf or something oh my god that's
normal but it went to another level last
night and I punched a hole in the wall
and I fractured my foot Wow how's your
hand it's all right I mean it's all
bandaged up right now it's okay
I luckily I didn't hit a stud in the
wall so you slammed through the white
the drywall that's pretty impressive
yeah you know I had to flex on them a
little bit did that wake you up just and
then you're like what yeah yeah I was
around that time usually I it's because
I have these really vivid dreams and
then I feel compelled to act them out
and and especially if they are very
intense or scary so do you remember what
you are dreaming yeah I was dreaming
that that the the ceiling was like
slowly lowering and I was gonna die I
was gonna like wish me like in Episode
four of star wars when they're in the
trash chute and so in my in my
sleepwalking brain if I didn't try and
get out of there I something would have
been I would have been squashed so I
punched a hole in the wall and did you
wait do you know if you woke up after
punching the wall or did the dream
continue how does that work do you wake
up when you all right yeah I didn't
really realize what was happening at
first but then I remember going to the
window and looking out and thence I I
expected to see the roof
lowering and like the the sky
disappearing and then once I realized
wait nothing's happening I kind of had a
realization that that I was fine and
that's usually what happens is I'm aware
that I'm doing these things but I'm not
in my room I see a whole other place and
then slowly it shifts to where I
actually am Jesus yeah that sounds
dangerous what if you jumped out the
[ __ ] window yeah that's weird me
because I currently live on a third
floor and there's been two instances
where I've gone to sleep with my balcony
door closed and then woken up and it was
wide open
how often does this happen steel maybe
what I mean times that I'm aware where
I'm actually waking up and realizing
that's happening maybe once or twice a
month maybe
oh but wood like how often it's like
when you wake up and the doors are open
so it's happening you're not even aware
of it that's that's very rare that's
happened maybe twice in life so that's
more rare it's usually I'm very
contained in my bedroom when this
happens and then I snap out of it fairly
quickly and your girlfriend was there
right she was there last night yeah what
was her reaction I mean she thought I
was gonna like go [ __ ] The Shining
god girl she was she was terrified
understandably yeah so tell wait tell me
what happened when you when you kind of
snapped out of it what was the
conversation like well she was trying to
calm me down but then I think nor
normally when I do this it's so kind of
low-key in kind of goofy I actually did
it two nights ago and she said she woke
up and I was looking around the room
kind of picking things up and she was
like what are you doing and I was like
don't you hear the animals don't you
hear about the don't you hear they're
animals in here she's like just come
back to bed it's finally and I got I
like got closed I like squatted down I
was like animals are in here and she was
like just go to sleep it's fine and then
I did and we laughed about it this one
was a lot more intense
so in my mind as well because she was
talking to me she was in my dream where
I could feel her distress and I think
that pushed me even more because I was
like oh we're both gonna get washed by
this thing I need to get us out of here
hmm
and yeah so I I went to Urgent Care this
morning and they're connecting me with
the sleep sleep specialist to finally
kind of figure out what's going on I
wonder what do you have to do because
like what you have to strap yourself
when you sleep I mean there do you know
like Mike Birbiglia the comedian have
you heard of him I don't know what he's
a stand-up comic but anyways he had he
had he has really bad sleepwalking to
where he threw himself out of a
second-story window at like a Hilton
once he just smashed through the glass
and woke up on the lawn and they had to
take him to the hospital he he has to go
to sleep in a sleeping bag and his wife
zips him up and he puts on oven mitts
holy [ __ ]
I'm hoping that that's not the case with
me oh [ __ ]
well your girlfriend at least hey she
got she got a trial by fire up here
I mean she's ready for anything now
right yeah I mean she was so supportive
she was she was really incredible she's
been you know helping me all this
morning because I had to go the doctor
and just just being incredible in every
sense so she's been great good job there
well well well I look forward to I look
forward to pictures of you strapped in a
suitcase with mom with men's yeah you
need a sleeping sack it's like you do
that with babies what if it's too hot
can you get a sec that look what are you
doing the summer we got to get a summer
sack like a breathable mesh mesh sack
amen we gotta get a mess oh you got to
get a sack for every season
no but I look forward to you getting
treatment for that that sounds really
scary so yeah yeah but you know it's a
it could have been worse so I'm scared
about you jumping out of window though I
don't want that to happen well like I
said well you know I'm moving in two
weeks and I'm not gonna be up that
you'll be on the ground floor yes so you
can jump out the window that just wait
two weeks yeah it'll be for the next two
weeks you know it apparently is like a
family thing my dad was a kid would uh I
don't think it actually I don't know but
it would happen to him - when he was a
kid where he would wake up in a
neighbor's shed like five oh that's
[ __ ] crazy
he would go walk around the neighborhood
oh you know I had a friend in college
who had something similar and I did not
I didn't really understand what it was
but I think it sounds like something
similar to you and I remember one day he
we were drinking and he woke up and
started peeing on he was in college so
he had roommates they were in a small
room two beds and he started peeing on
his roommates bed well the other dude
was in it [ __ ] damn yeah I can use that
now mark my territory and go oh I was
sleepwalking okay what's about Wow well
we wish you well thank you
yeah it's all good my foot hurts but
it's fine it's it's not too bad
well it's good I mean in a way it's
really a compliment to Sam that you were
trying so desperately to save her life
you punched him hole in the wall that's
awesome I was trying so hard I I beat
myself up I fought the wall and lost I
fought the wall in the wall won yeah I
also heard something about you in you
were out cleaning up garbage after uh
the writing is that right yeah I mean I
don't want to cut myself on the back or
anything I do that's a great thing you
did how does that work is that organized
or you just show up a start cleaning
[ __ ] up no I just just Sam and I cruised
over there cuz and no one really cared
cuz it was just so chaotic over there
you know
right right near where I live that
neighborhood was was hit pretty hard I
think like the second night so we a lot
of people are just showing up with stuff
trash bags and window cleaners and
there's some good people out there yeah
that's right I wouldn't even think to do
that it's just like good ass
that's just like a good ass thing to do
good job again that's a really nice
thing to do
thank you and everybody just drove out
there I was like I'm gonna help clean up
a lot of good people out there yeah
that's really there's really good people
in the world I wish I was one of them
but you contributed you you did your
thing speaking of good people we've got
Jake Paul who was spotted among the
looters in an Arizona mall of course he
was I've got videos here let's see here
he is spotted during a looting someone
else's in stories there you can see
they're outside a PF Changs mob then I
guess they stole from the restaurant
there so people are saying he did yeah
yeah yeah they're doing or why I feel
like he's inside the mall breaking [ __ ]
and Jake is there cuz why not you know
of course here he is standing next to
someone firing fireworks at the mall
let's see he was number one trending
people were hating on him so bad
they're trying to light them all on fire
with fireworks okay and finally let's
see here
here he is calling the cops [ __ ]
idiot I'm trying to get the whole
perspective here before I make a
judgment call [ __ ] idiot walked right
here I walked right up to them these
[ __ ] idiots teargas me I'm doing [ __ ]
bro looking on pointing guns on me
pointing guns at me right now swear to
god no cat that's teargas bro [ __ ] you
guys
recipes George bored [ __ ] y'all okay so
he was getting slammed and he actually
got charred would he get charged for
just trespassing I think criminal
trespassing cuz he was in the mall and
he released a video about it
here we go
I'm not reading that's too much text
here's what he says about the vodka
bottle which is apparently the thing
exploding someone comes up to me while
I'm filming just hands me something I
didn't even know what it was at the time
to later find out that someone handed me
a bottle of vodka for what reason I
don't know seconds later I set the
bottle on the ground still not even know
I would actually have to I have to say I
totally believed that Jake Paul was not
looting right I think in his mind he's
there he's a vlogger he just wants to
capture what's going on that I totally
get and I I I'm sure that he wasn't out
there looting the part about this story
that I find hilarious is that in that
Paula G video you just saw which I'll
reopen he links a fundraiser brings
things on the side which you'll see is
was organized by this guy that [ __ ]
Asian and I don't think we're allowed to
say [ __ ] anymore is that right uh well
it's his name
you think his name is [ __ ] Asian I'm
kidding it's raised $43,000 okay and he
put this fundraiser here but what's
funny is that Jake Paul didn't actually
make that fundraiser here we go so this
is the guy who made that fundraiser and
here's his response to Jake Paul I want
you guys to imagine something real quick
okay imagine make a video about black
lives matter and you put a fundraiser
and it raises around 32,000 dollars
within the first three days now imagine
Jake Paul makes a video three days later
and puts your fundraiser
that's me the organizer and then you go
to Jake Paul's Twitter and you see that
he's taken all the crap so there's that
this person says Jake has raised thirty
two thousand dollars in 20 minutes and
he says with y'all's help Lowell and
then you've got people saying I love you
so much for doing this I don't know
how does Jake keep [ __ ] up it's like
why would you use someone else's
fundraiser and then take all the credit
you know you didn't raise $30,000 in 20
minutes
oh really just like not even stopping to
think for a second like what that has to
be the only explanation honestly but why
did you link this guy's fundraiser to
begin with I think probably here's the
tweet with y'all's help he didn't raise
any of that money dude uh it's awesome
why would he do it who knows probably
just carelessness easier lazy easy lazy
add it up yeah exactly he doesn't have
to do anything gotta say lately Logan is
showing a lot of character and growth
saying some good things on the other
hand Jake is just like Jake is honestly
just the family reject
I think like and it wasn't even a
fundraising video and you know he just
put it on the side for good optics I
think it is a certain point when is he
gonna start to understand the
consequences of the things he's doing
this is a slowdown you know even if
you're not looting yourself why are you
hanging out again around people or
looting showing it to your followers
maybe think that it's not a good idea
and actually he wasn't really filming he
was just kind of just hanging out there
you have it so dick Poe was it a lot of
[ __ ] I have to say a hundred percent I
don't think he was looting but I do find
it hilarious
the fundraiser scheme yeah it's just
stupid man we've got a lot to talk about
today how long we been going there's
another phenomenon going on in our
country
regarding the corona virus people
refusing to wear masks I've read a
report that if people actually wore
masks when the outside we could reduce
the transmission of the virus to one
which means one person on average
infects one other person which would
basically stop it from exponentially
spreading completely but people again I
don't know how this became a political
issue but people are straight up
refusing to wear masks and there's a
Karen invasion if you guys probably know
about the Karen invasion I mean this is
a this up Karen strikes again
cuz I got a whole Twitter account
dedicated to this but I think this needs
to be a presidential platform about what
are we can do about all these Karen's
here's a Karen outside a Gelson's
shopping grocery store who is refusing
to wear a mask
and making it the world's problem wait
the music
yeah there's Michael Jackson in the
background but we can't I can't hear the
video yeah I mean there's no point if
you're pulling out the audio I think it
stops at this point stop it oh here go
ahead
lift it how's that helping when you're
gonna do shopping for me I'm gonna give
you my bank information how do i do how
do I do the transaction go away Michael
knows at the time policies which state
that they will shop for me take mine my
money that sounds great like a fantastic
service I know it she's bitching because
they won't let it so that's a private
property still going on about how my
rights are being violated [ __ ] it's
girl sins but they're offering this job
for you that's awesome love at IU cream
there's more I work for Costco and I'm
asking this member to put on a mask
because that is our company policy so
either wear the mask and I'm not doing
exciting every classroom winner man
that's the type of dude right there boy
listen to him he goes because I woke up
in a free country
it's Costco its Costco there's a
pandemic going on if you're down here
it's their private business they can
tell you they could keep you from coming
in just because they don't like the way
that you look actually I don't think
that's discriminatory but they could
definitely stop you from not wearing a
mask you know you can't go in a store if
you're going to store not wearing a
shirt they can ask you to leave no shoes
no shirt no service
you know the slogan done oh you don't
know that I guess it's a beach thing you
can't Cruise in the stores they say if
you come in without a shirt we will
remove you mm-hmm
so homie you're not gonna go could think
that you have a constitutional right to
cruise around Costco shirtless right you
know
yes so you're gonna take this car for me
I have a cooler star I'll give you my
card
he's gonna take the card away - yeah you
just got [ __ ] own get boiler paper in
there - yeah the gold mine nope not
today [ __ ] love it
this one is uploaded by a channel put on
a mask
this one is uploaded by a channel called
First Amendment defenders by the way
when you wear a mask you are protecting
other people when you go into a public
space and don't wear a mask you are
saying I don't give a [ __ ] about all you
other people yes people are wearing
masks to protect you that's how it works
and you are not extending that same
courtesy I cannot enter the store
without a much longer Walmart
if I if I have a medical condition that
prevents me from wearing a mask like you
what is all this like hypotheticals what
medical condition prohibits someone from
wearing a mask is that even a thing I
don't think it is a thing actually
because I keep seeing that coming up and
people are saying that is not even a
thing
yeah what would what private I mean sick
people where I'm actually if you do have
a medical condition then you should wear
the man you should be what you really
shouldn't get coving yeah I can't think
of a medical addition we're like sorry I
need to make sure I don't breathe in
viruses Mike medical condition wants me
to breathe in deadly viruses medical
condition that prevents tomorrow
addition yeah don't a stupidity yeah
what law does that refer to only just to
rats the employees it's like dude I'm
not I'd have nothing to do with this bro
my job is to prevent idiots like you
from entering the store I'm asking you
what you're the one telling me that I'm
not theirs there is just a ton of people
in the world who are this dumb you need
to learn the laws
it's imagine my well I can't go in there
then sup guy look at the scene of a
medical condition I can't wear Matt what
is that medical condition sir just you
can't to be uncomfortable for I can't be
uncomfortable my skin is sensitive okay
so you're gonna spread Kove it to
everybody in Walmart fantastic there you
go you think you have the right to ask
me that
when you own a new I'm a right to ask me
that I get I love this you don't have a
right to ask me that but I have a right
to go in your store without a mask do
you think if I have a disability you
have any right to talk to me about the
California state law it's not I want to
see this guy's reflection I wanna know
if he looked like 70 minutes this you
guys yeah these poor mothers and it
keeps going I'll tell you what there's
there's a lot of this stuff there
settled upon male equivalent of Karen
yeah I think they're called Chad Chad
Chad surgeon I heard somebody I saw some
yeah you're right Chad is the Alpha
right well what can it be the same guy
like Chad I feel like whining about a
mask you know it doesn't seem like a
very alpha move to me a Ralph Ralph I
just googled it it's Kevin or a Todd Oh
Kevin
oh poor Todd that's your brother's name
it's my dad's name oh yeah your dad's my
dad's middle name is Kevin - does your
dad wear a mask Zach
yes he does he's a Todd Anna Kevin hey
what was your brother's name I remember
we were Jeff Jarrett produce enough
names in your family I know I'm the only
good one so this is a Karen so what is
it Todd or Kevin Todd er I mean it's
this reddit thread what do you think
which one I like both of those yeah
actually like God sighs I like
apologies to your that your father on
that so with this this is my favorite
she's going full Karen over not wearing
a mask so and also bringing black lives
matter into it as well good guy at Karen
take the mic
come on sweater refresh the page where
the world is yours truly
all right so mid market basket and they
tell me I need a mask but we're in a
free country and I'm not wearing a mask
because it's a private proper you dumb
dumb idiot stupid broad you have no
constitutional right to go inside a
private property medical issues that I
can't wear a mask I refuse to put a mask
wine I'm in a free country I refused to
put a mask on I'm a freak out you have a
medical condition don't go there stay at
home there is a no Mac there's no
medical condition that prevents you from
wearing a mask
none if you're that sick you should be
in a hospital I'm healthy
make up your mind Garrard are you
healthier do you have a medical
condition just throwing everything at
the wall man this woman is not used to
being cold no not to wear a mask I have
civil liberty rights she's making it
some weird race issue like she's doing
everything at the wall no goddamn mask
I'm not the manager Americans need to
speak up what do you think about it this
is tyranny this is this is fascism
wearing a master in a pant dammit this
is outrageous
this is white privilege when she's so
outraged when requested aware a mass
during a pandemic and she's the victim
right she this is our this is the most
outrageous ever encountered in her life
as a white female this is the civil
right this is our civil rights movement
whose protection urge is sick and you
feel comfortable wearing a mask you
should we it's okay
good job be careful for your freedom
that's being taken away for you because
you have it for your standing them it's
okay to be uncomfortable for one hour
why freedom it's really not the end of
the world this is definitely the Karen
apocalypse this is the ultimate Karen
video black lives me Adam you have a
black live Lunada protests all lives
matter why'd you get all races about it
just black lives very healthy I get the
cult you gets like it's like a cult
allottee but I'm standing here wait for
the manager and I don't care
hi guys because this is a real fight
because they're taken away yes for a
woman she actually thinks she's having
like a civil liberties battle right now
she's Rosa Parks of the Rev the new
world but this is the disinformation
that goes on like all so what does it
mean I'm healthy you could have it and
not know nobody she said it to people
for two weeks she says it's just a
common cold she said that that's what
she thinks
so she's smarter than everybody do you
understand that if she got it it's just
a common cold but she also has
pre-existing conditions apparently so
for someone like her it will not be just
like a common cold
she's like I'm lying about that obvious
I'm lying about our amendment rights
they have taken away a tremendous I
don't wait in line to come into short
and amass like this I'm healthy I want
the manager want the store manager yeah
yeah I'm really upset because I love
that it's not your fault you're doing it
you
this young man has to do his job but I
feel is about healthy I do not know why
Karen you could disagree with me but you
know what people died in nursing homes
in my family because you could see them
no funerals but they haven't a funeral
for the black guy that's okay some
people did die nice man
but my ass like me I did too and all the
people that I know that was parents
these lives mattered but those are just
a common flaw huh so her family members
who died of Kovac didn't create a few no
but George Floyd got a funeral hmm
twisted world but why was George Floyd
allowed to have a funeral but not her
family members I'm serious Oh
I mean why was her why was George Floyd
allowed to have a public funeral and not
her family members she raises a good
point actually
what's the point there weren't a lot of
common Colvard still around
George Floyd had covered I'm just sorry
I'm trying to understand why is that a
bad point I mean assuming she's not
making it up which is highly likely if
she had a family member that died in the
midst of the lockdown from kovin that's
a very there's a completely different
set of circumstances and timeline okay
let's cut this yeah cut that I just
generally curious that's okay Maddy but
my ass like me attitude and all the
people that I know most parents fear we
just don't I wasn't yeah it's okay we're
gonna cut that yeah you can cut it yeah
that [ __ ] hell it's hot as a mother
we should just wrap it up after this no
yes five and just that's it no Kim team
names man so home
[Music]
[ __ ] you ready damn yeah
okay I'm gonna proceed okay so that is
the Karen apocalypse and then there's
actually one other good one here
the Orange County Council meeting which
is phenomenal frankly a bunch of people
stormed City Council and Orange County
asks how disgusting how shameful to
protest today they have in in the
greater LA area in California a lot of
places they say that if you're in public
you have to wear a mask they've mandated
it so these people are here to protest
this outrageous outrageous violation
breathing freely building your immune
systems without masks how disgusting how
shameful how criminal how corrupt this
is a this is a hoax it's a fraud
there's nobody dying in excess of any
other year in the last few are you aware
of that stop listening to absolute
charlatan doctors like this dr. Chow who
I wouldn't go your time is up thank you
dr. Chow hammer on her hundred people
showed up to [ __ ] out the board to
speak out against masks where I have to
breathe in co2 when God gave this body
the ability to extract that from my body
and now you want me to put it back in so
that's crazy I never heard that so they
say that by wearing a mask there
rebreathing co2 and in violation of God
of course somehow they don't think
they're breathing fresh air because
they're wearing a mask
wow that's crazy I mean you can't that's
just that doesn't make any sense I mean
you can't live on co2 you will get
lightheaded you would eventually pass
out people wear these masks all day
every day doctors wear them for 15 hours
straight they're not passing out and
dying you get your breathing the same
air lady you're not you're not in there
at home then
no wear a mask you know this is all
Facebook this is fate Facebook was
responsible for this I swear to God
Facebook didn't exist this would not be
happening only on Facebook and people
get together and agree that wearing mask
results in you breathing an increased
amount of co2 my body I have natural
rights as a sovereign citizen of a thank
you it's your timing so it's a rumor
kneeling on the necks of the people all
you are continuing making people wear
masks to the police kneeling at George
Floyd oh by the way and I love how
there's no relation to the two incidents
they're just hijacking yeah brutal
losing a metaphor you know yeah I know
but it'll work
yeah I understand but they're using this
unrelated police brutality yeah yeah to
try to make their point about see
wearing masks during a pandemic okay
that's this is a caring collective this
is like the board of Karen's was that
Rick and Morty thing with all the Rick's
the Rick consortium what do they call it
nobody Wow sure yes Wow is there the
Council of Rick yes the Council of Rick
the Council of Karen thank you
this is the she imposed the mandatory
mask
order god bless her soul she resigned
after receiving death threats
he's the new chief health officer go
ahead and with the sound from sight I
begin with the question are you smarter
than a 5th grader
I remember teaching my own 5th graders
about the respiratory system these 10
year olds understood the most basic
important element needed by the human
body is oxygen so I asked you why in the
name of science and health would you
require people especially children to
wear a mask only to rebreathe the waste
product the body wants to get rid of can
you point to one person that hasn't that
died from why are you talking about guys
a teacher yeah surprise name the one
person on the whole earth that has
dropped dead from not getting oxygen
because they're wearing a mask making
our children wear Mouse is contrary to
the medical experts and it's fundamental
they need to be exposed to bacteria in
the air playing on jungle gyms kids need
sunlight exercise interaction asks if
you deny them now at 20 years you're
gonna have a population of MU
immunosuppressed antisocial adults who
can only interact by a zoom in face time
and need gloves to shake your hand
very light it is a pandemic it's just
one year ideal they can't deal with this
it's not fun just one [ __ ] year we
asked you to wear a mask and be
responsible this is Facebook
discriminated five times in the last two
days I have been actually turned away
not going these businesses without a
mask although I have a health condition
where a maza be back on the field not in
two weeks now
as you can see Taylor's got a soccer
uniform on and we're still not playing
soccer like really like you know I mean
are we still talking about this like
it's over you know this lockdown I mean
you're looking at none of it mark my
words
that lady's good it's over based on what
that you're tired of being
yes how are we we are so doomed kovat is
coming back we are just gonna be I'm
telling you dude when the fall starts
coming and the weather starts calling we
are gonna be decimated this is gonna be
a nightmare kovat is going to ravage
this country new zealand by the way that
of a single coating their back and
loving life same thing with China for
the most part but here in America land
to the Freak free to be ignorant is a
there's just so much disinformation we
are gonna be coveted out of our minds
covet Marty the president is not wearing
a mask so why do you think the president
doesn't wear a mask I think it's because
of the spray tan rubs off his face but
people say he likes to politicize them
well anyway he's gonna start having
rallies soon and he's not gonna require
people to wear masks or social distance
that's gonna be [ __ ] fantastic you see
that to go though you have to sign a
yeah memorandum yeah so if you go to a
trump rally you have to sign this
agreement registering below you
acknowledge that an inherent risk of
exposure cover 19 exists by attending
the rally you and any guests will
entirely assume all risks and agree not
to old Donald J Trump for president
incorporated or any of their affiliates
director office employees agents yada
yada yada liable for any illness or
injury supporters square the circle I
don't get it like they think it's
[ __ ] they think it's a hoax they
think it's not that dangerous but then
they're going to a rally and they have
to agree
not to sue and the chance that they get
it well they just they say well it's
just a legal thing what
good dude these these rallies because
first of all people like to compare it
to the protests the protests are
outdoors I have to say a lot of the
protests I've seen them wearing masks
and being very responsible with the mask
wearing mask wearing helps a lot being
outdoors the virus is is the cut down on
transmission is is cut down a lot when
you're outdoors it's mostly spread
indoors in close proximity without masks
that's the happy place for this virus to
spread I understand a lot of people say
well the protests are out there during a
pandemic and you're not giving them [ __ ]
well frankly look what are they
protesting they have to now's the time
what can you do you know they didn't
choose to depict it down there didn't
you think they I think a lot of people
would rather not be there during the
pandemic I mean they're going while
risking their lives to i think there'd
be a lot more people there if there
wasn't a pandemic mmm yes but that being
said they are being very responsible and
it's outdoors Trump's rallies are going
to be indoors populated by people that
don't believe this is a real issue not
requiring people to wear masks or social
distance these are gonna be super
spreading events that are gonna I'm just
do it it's gonna be [ __ ] epic the
whole world is gonna be recovered from
kovat and the United States is going to
be devastated this pandemic alone may
unseat us from our place of power in the
world forever forever
this is our undoing that's my prediction
we will be so devastated unemployment
numbers on stock market crashing deaths
[ __ ] it's just we are losing it we are
losing it I mean meanwhile China's back
to work
you know percent data and you know I go
to a resort nobody's wearing a mask then
I come here everybody's wearing a mask I
hope nobody thank you you
time it said he went and fought where
yeah where did you fight okay let's
bring your old dad out here in his fight
was for your freedom
my freedom here today I don't know he
fought for your right to not wear a mask
and guess it's dammit
as our robots or what not so please stop
imposing Chinese communism tactic this
is America these we need our essential
bread I think she's trended chime into
like essential services I need my
essential breath please join you on must
on his trip to Mars and let us vote for
our breath please let us breath from
what do you how do you even argue with
that level of stupidity you know it's
crazy ps5 was announced y'all ps5 the
world is hyped the memes have started
the porn I have to say the way it looks
is not that impressive I don't like it I
don't like the asymmetrical CD why is
there even CD slot it looks to me like
if someone rendered like 10 years ago
what a ps5 would look like in 2020
that's funny because it was probably
developed was exactly idem years ago
that's what it looks like dude why is
there a CD drive
seriously just I think like let's get
over that well there's there's two
versions oh the deluxe edition doesn't
have the CD drive no digital edition oh
I can get it with or without the CD
Drive yeah I'm skipping this [ __ ]
some people have you live in a place
with shitty internet you still need to
buy the hard disk because it's
downloading a giant game takes forever
what is this
that's the cube this isn't a real thing
is it yes Xbox
that's next book oh I thought that was a
mean this is really what it looks like
yes yeah I like this one better I came
by like away but it's way better it
in a way it's a lot more modern than
that or this is way better
what do I need this for I'm all about
that Xbox cube yes
I mean sure but I'm down the way what do
we see here
these are memes Oh free yeah I tried
that fridge I would not buy the
PlayStation water cooler oh it's an
espresso kind of thing
let's see PS 5 first Xbox series x-man
xbox needs to name their [ __ ] better I'm
just like there's like just slightly off
with their design and branding and
everything like that cube is almost
there they could make it they could take
that same cube but make it look a lot
more slick just called the Xbox cube
then I'm in Xbox Series X Y I don't know
they are out of control and then the act
the X the latest Xbox was what was it
called Xbox one yeah xbox one Xbox Xbox
360 Xbox one and now Xbox really sucks I
hate them I might buy PS 5 just because
I hate the name of the Xbox so much
fridge vs. router that's true the PS 5
is the eye of Mordor I just heard that
all the PS 5 a whole long was just a fan
oh I get that way what I really don't
get how did you get this manual thank
you thank you I have uh something to say
about that meme actually it was posted
to our subreddit yeah last night when I
woke up this morning I went on our sub
just to check it out and that meme had
about I don't know 900 up votes or
something and about 50 reports and then
I went into the comments and every
comment was like what the [ __ ] is this
this is the stupidest thing I've ever
seen this isn't funny this [ __ ] sucks
really is extremely divisive really the
most divisive post I have ever seen
why is it really console war [ __ ] like
because you have like fanboys who are
actually like I'm Pro PlayStation and
I'm Pro Xbox which you think Wow if you
think while people are so divisive if
people can really get hostile and
divided over that then we are truly
[ __ ] as a if I could write a meme and
I'm really not the person to do it but I
really thought this one was funny yeah
I'll officially give my stamp oh maybe I
call undeleted then although I do not
understand the relation to h3 although
we make fun we made allow it
wait would you remove the den well again
it was it was causing like a meltdown
ever seen a post with this many repair
does that mean don't get it a villain
from DBZ I have to say that to both
companies that they could do so much
better with the design I really don't
get it what's the problem what's so hard
to design a cool located Oh what the
[ __ ] people been up all night with this
[ __ ] yeah you know who did really well
then intend to switch yes which they've
Nintendo always does it man they always
get it right
you know actually that's not true the
breed boy what was the one before the
switch the Wii U Wii U yeah I think
their big mistake was branding it as a
Wii you got to move on and the Wii U
yeah yeah so how much is the playstation
5 they announced oh give a prize oh wow
it's gonna be bad I bet you'll be like a
thousand bucks no no way
it says here Sony hasn't confirmed the
price yet but analysts predict it will
be 500
that's how much the last one was that
seems fine I'm surprised that Xbox
didn't go more like the GameCube style
GameCube that's a callback
thank you you yeah oh you mean the noon
here I don't know what do you know about
GameCube this fuel yeah this this looks
epic the Gamecube was awesome
this still looks better than both of
those that just came did the game it was
like the best console look man one of
the best I never had it I'm just talking
from make the cube just talking about a
design right perspective so anyway it's
been so long since a new console came
out I'm ready I want it I want it I need
it and then the thing is like I have a
really old PlayStation 4 because then
they they upgrade it with like the
PlayStation 4 X or the PlayStation 4 X
plus extreme the places you're for 4k X
double D black comm and I'm like I don't
want to buy any of these new consoles
just so it goes faster I want the new
console I don't want to buy three of the
same console you know what I'm saying
anyone feel me out there
mmm-hmm I don't buy consoles because I'm
not a pleb I don't play video games I
don't play video games yeah back me up
but I wouldn't buy it if it look cooler
I probably good yeah you would buy the
Xbox three acts seven no not the
PlayStation boy get the router the neck
here Sony here
Wi-Fi extender yeah and for our final
story I have to talk about we have not
talked yet talked about on the podcast
the keemstar beef drama that took place
over the past month how long ago was
that first video come out holy [ __ ]
let me see keemstar content nuke Wow
when did this released May 19th it's
almost been a month wow that's crazy
I mean the video where you threatened
his life with a nuclear
exactly yeah cuz we all got nukes in our
house don't [ __ ] with me I'll drop a
nuke read on you boy
guard [ __ ] oh by the way so I haven't
talked about it but now's the time
because there's been a lot of
developments now let me let me preface
this part by saying for the last three
years I have tried my best to just take
what everybody's been saying try to
parse out the reasonable stuff and
dismiss the unreasonable stuff and take
the criticism the best way that I can
and just ignore the rest I mean for
anyone that's been paying attention
there's always been a huge influx of
videos critical about me I think in part
because people are either disappointed
that my views I think a lot of it stems
from either people who disagree with me
politically who sees me as someone who's
not what they thought I was people who
miss our old videos and people who just
generally think I'm a hypocrite and
don't come whatever yeah oh yeah
and that that's fine and then and then
part I do think that there's been like a
whole economy of h3 videos so a lot of
people are trying to cash in on that as
well and it's all fine I mean hey I do
that too you know what I'm saying we all
do that here on YouTube do you do to
stay afloat and stay relevant on YouTube
so there's nothing wrong with any of
those things to do per se but the stuff
that is wrong is when for example some
ordinary gamer made that whole video
about me about donation shaming Jeff
Bezos and how I was a hypocrite and I'm
like dude this guy this is this is
getting out of control this guy's the
whole premise of his videos long and
he's using it to draw all these
conclusions about me that are just
horrible his video was getting was like
blowing up it had over a million views
99% like people had no problem accepting
the fact that I was pretty much just the
biggest piece of [ __ ] that ever lived
basically
and it's just basically taken for
granted at this point so I saw that
video I said man I I I don't think I
could ignore this anymore I think I need
to start correcting the record on some
of these things because for three years
I sat back and I just cried to accept it
and I let it happen and I was in a bad
place frankly emotionally and and not in
a good place to kind of take this stuff
on anyway but I think I've learned that
if I as much as I want to can't just let
people say whatever they want about me
because it just perpetuates fake [ __ ]
and somehow on YouTube or the people who
who continue making videos about me they
take my silence as an admission of guilt
and so it's important for me to now when
I see people lying about me or
distorting things about me to actually
come out and correct the record because
it just snowballs out of control and
that's how you ended up with this video
like go kanaru because I was silent
silent silent everybody has all these
crazy conspiracies about what this means
that means that this means and then all
of a sudden you've got a video like coca
narrows which that thesis is basically
that I'm a terrible human being well as
thesis was that I'm a hypocrite attack
can't take criticism but you get what
I'm trying to say so to address the
keemstar controversy there's been a new
conspiracy theory being afforded by
leafy and keemstar that I am let's see
I'll pull up leaf he's if he's tweet
here he just tweets out uh none
unprompted I believe h3h3 productions is
trying to get my channel deleted what
had to private all my videos just got
second channel strike for harassment on
my new videos another strike and my
channel gets deleted
he says the videos received strikes
where the h3h3 productions went into I'm
Alex one nearly at the
same time again I don't know if it's a
seriously but yeah that's my current
situation so here you say I believe you
open with that I believe H how what
youtuber has the power to get video
channels deleted I mean the whole
premise is weird I feel like I feel like
I'm become the George Soros of YouTube
with just a lightning rod for
conspiracies that because I know all
goes back of course to uh but also if it
gets removed for harassment it's just
you don't have to report it it's just
YouTube's their own policy being in
forest yeah it doesn't mean that you
personally ask them to remove it because
of harassment I think in their minds
they think that I called Susan Wojcicki
and said hey this videos harassing me
can I get some water it's so hot here
ice do we have ice-cold water
dying our AC is broken anyway
I truly think that they just think that
Thank You Zack that I have Susan on
speed dial because I took a picture with
her once and then of course I've never
even seen the video he made it but I
don't know what he's even referencing
what video about me because he's made
several and I said nothing of value was
lost you know obviously when you come at
me saying a street she's trying to get
my channel deleted like what obligation
do I have to feel sorry for you I don't
[ __ ] care about I find it so funny to
that leafy Thank You Zack
Lisa leaf he gives using clips of me
going uh I'd love to see him succeed in
today's climate and it only took like a
month before his channel is almost
removed and I was right exactly what you
were talking about course cuz their
policies has changed so much you just
can't get away with the same [ __ ] you
used to and and hello I mean the reason
we said it is because we're doing with
YouTube all the time with the podcast
with everything you have to adjust
there's certain things we could do a
while
go that we can't do anymore you can't
talk about anything you want you can't
show anything you want right you can't
you just can't you have to Gerald it's
all I wasn't even saying that to be like
rude or to leafy I was just saying I
leafy I know what kind of content you
make what kind of content made you
famous I'd love to see if you can do
that today and I think the answer was a
resounding no but instead I'm I'm
perpetuating a conspiracy to get his
channel removed so let's go down this
meme hole oh by the way I do want to
point out one thing that I thought was
hilarious
so leafy who's tweeting out I believe a
street reproduction is trying to get my
channel at the same time he's telling
his friends to message me and get his
channel reinstated so do you believe it
or not he says I'm reaching out because
I still talked to leafy his shelves one
strike away from termination and one of
the videos is about you I know for a
fact that you personally didn't take it
down but I also know that maybe you can
help him in a way if you even want to I
said he asked you to reach out he said
yeah I told him I don't think you took
it down his video and that if he got I
told him I don't think you took down his
video and that he got in touch with you
perhaps you could help him bro I can't
help you and I can't remove your video
what can I do for you can't do anything
it was [ __ ] youtuber the same as you
it's weird why would you help him while
he's like publicly bashing you exactly
so crazy the whole thing like dude what
the [ __ ] people don't understand what
they're saying anymore you just put out
in the world that I am trying to get
your channel suspended but I'm the
[ __ ] for saying basically [ __ ] off
right like it's so crazy how I just
can't win in the eyes of some of these
people and then all these little
commentary channels are scrambling just
to prove what an [ __ ] I am or to
prove that it was me because I said
nothing of value was lost
anyway which is funny like come on yeah
this is obviously just making a joke
yeah I don't have to like leafies
content I mean what the [ __ ] and then of
course I I said of course I'll spell it
out I had not because I know that I'm
living the conspiracy theory world now I
had nothing to do with that I never
reported his videos it's very bizarre
that he thinks I will some godlike power
to remove his videos but no it's not me
sorry keemstar responds with a picture
of me and Susan that's it that's all me
and Susan that's the source of the whole
conspiracy is that we met with her 20
minutes here at the play by the way I
changed my Twitter banner to commemorate
that meeting I hope you guys enjoy it
this is my new banner on YouTube
high-res by the way so anyway so this is
Kent I think this is Kim stars basically
his way of trying to get revenge is to
fuel all these crazy conspiracies about
me but know I had nothing to do with
that I mean I don't even know video he's
referring to and then this is the best
part right Team YouTube tweets out to
leafy if they respond to him the tweet
of him saying I believe HD is trying to
get my channel deleted they say yo our
policy team confirmed that your videos
were removed by mistake both of your
videos are backup and you should no
longer see the strikes on your channel
thanks for bearing with us
so YouTube says it was a mistake on
their end does anybody correct the
record or apologize to me no well they
only said that because they got caught
what that he says it in a way that he's
just saying like maybe you know but he
still puts it out there so it's still he
said I believe H he's trying to get my
channel deleted what's even parsing
words about that by the way what is his
evidence okay what is his evidence like
really
what's his evidence that I'm trying to
get his channel deleted what what is it
what is it it's crazy people will
believe anything about me on YouTube
it's [ __ ] crazy just blows my mind
so YouTube admits that it was a mistake
and then
keemstar this is when keemstar really
goes off the rails
he starts tweeting pictures of horses to
me tweeting pictures of horses yes so
with the horses pictures this has been
an ongoing thing maybe for like two
years or something I don't know when we
first it gets even older than the first
wave of like commentary channels that
started to hate us they they liked to
make a joke that I look like a horse
yeah I don't know where it comes from or
what but that's the so that's the
reference but I find it funny that
keemstar is not doesn't have the balls
to say it directly yeah anyone say
directly to me but he's just sending
these pictures of a horse yeah he's such
a petty little [ __ ] like he just he
can't accept ya can't talk about not
being able to accept criticism bro you
don't own up to anything and you just
start tweeting me pictures of what Wars
but wait it gets better okay so you
tweets pictures a little horse okay by
the way Irish first responded I don't
get it because I wanted him to be man
enough and explain what it is but then I
was like I want people to actually know
what he's doing so he said obviously is
meant for ela all the edgy kids always
say she looks like a horse okay either
you're beautiful gorgeous you're like
everybody knows you're like a queen Cale
well obviously it's fine you're someone
like King story isn't making fun of how
I look okay that's true I mean you can
start I know you're gonna listen to this
next time just tweet directly at me and
say what you have to say mmm it's true I
did block him though so yeah he'll block
them you know it's actually block and I
just don't want to see this [ __ ] anymore
and I was like well yeah go go for it
man keemstar blocks literally Kim
Starr's Twitter it's his safe space like
all of his response everyone responds to
his sweets are just dick writers cuz he
blocks anyone that even descents
yeah like I have a friend I have this
friend on on YouTube who I've recently
made his name is a star killer
star killer this guy's a this guy I
gotta give a shout-out to star killer
he's the only [ __ ] the road for
me on YouTube he made a whole rebuttal
to go kinnaras video like years ago to
defend me and say that Goku knows videos
are all points were all bad and he this
star killer this guy's a legend he wrote
this is a real rider died [ __ ]
so anyway he tweeted something at keep
start and he has like a couple hundred
followers on Twitter he got like a
couple of likes and keemstar blocked him
like just some random do it on two so
he's in the nitty-gritty just blocking
anybody
so yeah just block him I mean who cares
our fault it's done there you go
congratulations so he can't tweeted at
you so what should he do if he wants to
send more horse pictures she just say my
name and say exactly what he means say
this is ela yeah and what exactly does
he not like about my face he's
pretending like he's trying to pretend
like it's a dead horse meme that's not a
dead horse no he's not trying to pretend
he said that you like horses and he
heard about a friend okay he's not
pretending so then he keeps going oh
yeah I said obviously it's meant for ela
he said I'm simply trying to brighten
your meet at a French home mutual friend
told me like horses yeah so there you go
okay and then a day passes and he keeps
tweeted pictures of wars is that B he
goes h3 is a bad person I will attempt
to change and what a statement yeah
I'll attempt to change him into a good
person by tweeting a picture of a horse
of him every single day for a year
I hear he likes horses and it makes him
feel good if you want to help me reform
Ethan into a good person
tweet horses at him unfortunately
everybody thought this was the dumbest
fight he's trying to create a movement
and like yeah harass you maybe I said
having people some pigs lawyers nobody
[ __ ] day to me not just you well yeah
you he really started to get people to
harass me yeah any success
fully gotten some - I get a lot of hate
since the whole camp starting started
but it's weirdly racist even responded
to a black lives here it is yeah I'm
tweeting about all these police
brutality and he thinks now is the good
times it's a way to fixer-upper hordes
to me here's a picture of a reporter
getting pepper sprayed in the face on
provoked
and keemstar goes let's let's send him a
horse now's the good time epic it's
awesome it keeps going the court the
King star there's this there's not
enough [ __ ] going on in the world
so here's keemstar sending me a horse
again on the next day here's the top
comment bro cut it out we know you tried
but he gave you an L I think he
eventually stopped just because it was
just it was not well I kind of find it
interesting that he stopped around the
time that he got punished from uhmm I
didn't put that together well let's see
we could here's here's this his last
horse let's see this was on June 7th a
few extra horses today cuz I know you're
going through a lot right now have a
good day there's good old keemstar
basically saying I know you're having a
hard time so let me try to get people to
harass you and your wife more love him
good dude so then the next drama ler
comes out and of course he covers the
leafy story look how look how desperate
he is to try to make this seem like a
big deal oh you got exposed big time oh
yeah Jay Paul by the way Jake ball who
was caught riding and me have you ever
seen so animated
[Music]
he's Channel well we don't know but he's
gonna be that you know I called this
[ __ ] guy out for putting out false a
fraudulent
fake stories and he starts off by saying
he tried to take that leafy's Channel
well we don't know we don't know oh but
he's been accused of it but before we
get accused of it by who
leafy and you and you I love that it's
like he's but a cute got like multiple
personality yeah he's reporting on
himself he's been accused of it by me
that's a really good strategy for
reporting the news make an accusation on
Twitter and then you can report it as
news on dramaalert mm-hmm he's been
accused of it it's awesome it's that
story first we've he's like alright I
want to just make sure everyone knows
they usually did this and then he talks
about Jake Paul looting and then he
comes back to the story here let's see
h3h3 uploaded a video titled my
experience with the police and in this
video H 3 H 3 goes on to say that like
when he was younger he got pulled over
by the cops it was a fine experience he
got caught like drinking underage it was
a good experience all of his experiences
with the police throughout his life had
been good he thought police are the good
guy but now he's questioning if it
literally was the color of his skin and
why he received such good treatment from
the cops now I think it was a great
message so they put out there I applaud
him for it you however he started losing
subs h3h3 tweeted out first time being
happy that I lost subscribers from and
by the way I knew that I was gonna lose
subscribers when I made that video just
there's just a certain level of people
out there that either don't want to hear
it or disagree with the message or think
I'm like what did they call it virtue
signaling which is what people call
someone nowadays we're just caring about
anything is virtue signaling but anyway
I knew people were going on some video
basically h3h3 is saying that he has
some racist fans and they didn't like
that he was speaking out so their unsub
definitely how
whatever it seems to be all the chatter
that we're seeing online that it wasn't
racist fan sobbing it was people calling
h3h3 a hypocrite
because the whole basis of this video
people were unsub the second I uploaded
that video in mass I love how he's
taking something that isn't a story and
he's trying to blow it up but let's see
video is that the police are judging
people based on their skin color
and a clip came out of judging people
jogging maybe lost subscribers because
of this video oh no what is the video
rolling good that was like I was like
like these huge black dudes in there all
strapped they were all black there was
like 10 I'm just saying they were every
single one one was black I don't even if
there's eight dudes all in security and
they're all black I think that's worth
noting I just noticed their suit they're
all wearing suits they're all wearing
suits ya know they were cement and I
mean they were all like 6 5 y dudes yeah
yeah that's terrifying
as a six five black dude scary more than
a six five white do know is it supposed
to mean no it's the height maybe that
will scare you yeah so by the way I will
I don't know the context but I think
what I was trying to do is highlight my
I was almost trying to admit my how I
racially profile like how I I feel like
people do that obviously that came off
back I mean yeah it's bad but I think I
was just trying to own to the fact that
I do racially profile just because I
don't remember this story yeah I don't
remember what we were talking about but
I can tell that well we were right away
aware that that comment was like waste
on my reaction yeah wasn't cool and you
kind of I was trying to bounce off yeah
but yeah I totally agree that it's not
it it was a [ __ ] stupid ignorant
thing to say
that being said that's definitely not
why people were Sun subbing because this
do posted on Twitter the biggest
hypocrite on the planet way now that
video continued of Ethan saying the N
word multiple times obviously I'm not
gonna play that footage in here but wow
wow wow wow wow
you know I don't say a tree a tree or
Ethan he still could have made this
video and said the same exact thing he
just added in that he was wrong in the
past and that he has been racially
profiling people in the past and he
shouldn't have done that if you just own
that I think you still can make this
video so here this is where it came
started the news man really shines you
see where he's stopped watching the
video where he stopped watching the
video because if you actually watch my
[ __ ] video keep star you pathetic
excuse for a newsman this is the saddest
[ __ ] I literally put a whole segment in
there talking about how because I've
done research as somebody who has not
always been on the right side of racial
issues I've said that n-word on my
podcast and I thought I used it in a
context that made it okay I look back on
those clips with just embarrassment and
and shame but sometimes a hypocrite is
just a man in the process of changing I
mean the guy couldn't even finish the
video he's reporting on he can oh and
then keemstar actually got a two-week
suspension from youtube from the partner
program it made this really kind of
bizarre all of you hello guys I am
making this video to inform you of what
Scott was the Underwood 2016 a conscious
choice definitely because okay I mean
Underwood is definitely not someone you
want to identify with going on and - I
think guys you know I have been
suspended from the YouTube birthdays
like a murderer for tumors a couple
weeks ago I uploaded re uploaded the
gokhan ro documentary on h3h3
this original video was removed off a
youtube in 2019 when YouTube uploaded or
updated excuse me their policy on
bullying and harassment there was a
scene in that documentary that was
considered simulated violence against
the creator that being h3h3 when I
reload it this documentary - drama ler
we added it out the guns and replace
those with toilet plungers and we
removed the gun sound effects and
replace those with squeaky noises I
thought by doing that I was turning this
scene into comedy and that I wouldn't be
breaking the rules but I was wrong
YouTube's still seen that as bullying
harassment he's also seen it as a scene
letting violence against a creator and
that video was taken down I've never had
a strike on my yada-yada
so he's saying that I wasn't you
basically he is saying that mm-hmm
because later somewhat that's funny
because his messaging is kind of sloppy
because yes here in the video he
basically says okay I was not aware of
the terms but now I am aware and I
understand what the terms hello guys I
can't control these okay I much better
understand the rules but to also spread
the message out to the community of what
the rules are because when I uploaded
that video I didn't think I was breaking
the rules but that that is how strict
YouTube is on the bullying and
harassment guidelines and I understand
where they're coming from they're trying
to make the platform better for creators
and based on talking to them I
understand that I broke the rules and
that I am sorry Chuck it's funny
someone's like why are you apology
I won't find that but like why are you
apologizing if you're not sorry anyway
some ordinary gamer goes as much as I
love a good conspiracy theory I don't
believe even has a kill switch on
YouTube and that came started with
horrible take open your eyes
watch what's happening which is almost
like an ironic and ironically weird cue
and on conspiracy comment but apparently
he's being serious
so for after the video what's that was
that before or after I was after his
apology video but but you know what I
actually never watched the plunging
video so I was having a conversation
with go kanaru on twitter and he told me
we'll go watch the video and he sent me
the link so that okay let's see so the
video was removed for simulated violence
to see how much of an effort they
actually made to cover the gun well I
can't no I can't show me being murdered
but I can show the plunger this is that
once like I mean you can clearly see his
holding a gun right so I'm sure that you
like look so YouTube clearly just saw
this as them trying to skirt the
guidelines and and and really I'm not
surprised I mean anyone just watch this
scene out understands the context
shouldn't be surprised look at this he's
obviously holding a gun yeah I mean so
I'm not at all surprised that that this
video so anyway I'm not surprised and
I'm not surprised YouTube was angry
there cuz they're like look we removed
this video for having an assassination
scene and then keep star I'm really out
of spite
reuploads this video and skirts the
guidelines in a really kind of bad way I
said look if you wanted the video to
stay up
why not reshoot that outro scene and use
a plunger instead of a gun
it definitely would have stayed up for
like a couple of other people cut out
the scene at the end with the gun
there's three minutes at the end if you
cut it out the video stays up everyone
who uploaded this video on YouTube and
cut out the last three minutes the video
is still up I mean there's no conspiracy
you guys just [ __ ] like literally you
could have just cut out in the last
three minutes and that video would still
be up on your channel
so that's pretty much my than my thing I
just want to address this crazy
conspiracy that's going around and being
perpetuated by keep star really I guess
I had a way to get back at me that I
have a kill switch on YouTube a Susan is
on speed dial and I remove all videos
critical of me on YouTube even though to
this day is still just that one video
and if you cut out the last three
minutes it's still up on YouTube
mm-hmm so really there's zero videos
that have been removed of me for being
critical of me so obviously I take nope
I don't want to talk about this [ __ ] I'm
over it
everything that I said about Kim started
that I wanted to is in those three
videos I made it's out there but I do
feel the need to address these
conspiracy theories so that at least I'm
on the record explaining its [ __ ]
and why is it's both [ __ ]
gabbi's and evilly you do not for the
record resemble a horse you are a
beautiful young woman and I think you
are Gor and by the way I saw a lot of
people this is two horses are majestic
is [ __ ] I would say you are just the
right height
no bucket room fire baby for sure
top of the line good [ __ ] everyone was
saying how beautiful you are by the way
even the haters were like to be honest
EAL is beautiful the kids who were like
keemstar fans it's fine I don't need
anyone to feel bad for me I just find it
so petty
yeah of course and especially coming
from Q star I mean the guys know Brad
Pitt
you know if you want to talk about so
could Brad Pitt's any pictures of horses
sure I don't think yeah Brad Pitt yeah
if you're out there listening Brad you
can send pictures of our steel oh good
I'll be mad though I don't rap in
flirting with you
horses are not right yeah you should be
men if Brad Pitt is messaging you better
block Brad Pitt buck you start block it
I don't like where this is going well
that's about our show we did we've
talked about it all we've done it all
we've said it all isn't that right
yes sir so there you have it obviously a
little more political little more
engaged I do think it's important it's
not something we talk about every
episode but a just doing the time we're
living in it's a weird time and maybe
hopefully something good can come out of
this like I think it is I think we're
gonna see something happen I mean we
yeah man I don't want to be I don't want
to beat a dead horse I just want to [ __ ]
a horse not you I mean you know I mean
I'm not they look like I'm just using
his joke yeah but I think you're
beautiful and I do like having sex with
you but you're a human so that's it have
a great weekend guys we love we
appreciate you will be that we will be
back next week with William Osmond very
much looking forward to that and until
then have a fantastic week stay blessed
say safe where those masks and yeah just
put on a mask they'll be over soon it
will be it's not far I just write it out
a little more I mask forever no not
forever all right
Tata
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]